Hey look,
I found this book called Kinky Japanese.
I guess this is all Hentai stuff or
something.
Hey guys,
today I'm going to answer a question
that I wanted to ask them that a lot of
people who are beginners at Japanese
often asking it's should I learn a
Japanese dialect from the beginning or
should I just focus on the standard
language in my answer to that is
basically you should focus on the
standard language.
Before I came to Japan,
I was planning to come to the kinky
region or the Kansai region.
This is also known,
that's the area around Osaka and Kyoto
and Kobe.
I was planning to come to this region
already.
So I knew that I would be encountering
the local dialect.
So I bought this book because I wanted
to know some of the dialect beforehand
and then I got here and I'll tell you my
experience and what happened once I got
here.
Basically,
I think you should focus on the standard
language,
um,
because because the dialects are just
not really a big deal in Japan anymore
with the Japanese language,
they were like 100 years ago,
you know,
the dialects were quite different than
people would have to try really hard to
communicate with speakers from other
dialects.
But now basically everyone speaks
standard Japanese with some components
of the dialect,
but they've become much more standard in
recent generations,
you know,
through education and through,
uh,
the media,
the national media that's based in
Tokyo.
People are learning the standard
language and that's becoming the model
that they,
they copy.
So the exceptions are when you meet
elderly people,
they'll often speak like a heavier
dialect and they might say a lot of
dialect words.
When a younger person would use the
standard words,
uh,
it's also true sometimes in working
class neighborhoods or with less
educated people and also deeper in the
countryside,
you will hear more of the dialect as
well.
But basically with the younger
generations that mainstream Japanese
people,
they speak mostly the standard language
with some bits of the dialect mixed in.
So it's not really essential that you
learn those bits,
uh,
it's more essential that you learned the
foundation of Japanese have standard
Japanese and then once you're here you
will just,
you'll pick up some of the elements of
the dialect from your environment and
through your casual interactions.
So it's not really critical that you
study it.
You don't have to avoid the dialect,
like,
I bought this book,
but I use this just basically,
uh,
just as a supplement just for fun just
to,
just to get familiar with the bit of the
dialect before I came here.
And it was good.
It was a good idea because once I got
here,
I understood those dialect elements when
I heard them.
But that's just as an extra supplement
for fun and for familiarization,
uh,
I would focus on the standard language.
So the direction,
not a big deal.
That's one thing.
A second reason is that people will just
tend to speak to you and standard
Japanese anyway because you're a 400
learning Japanese.
So they will simplify and standardize
their language to try to help you.
So you won't hear the dialect being
spoken to you directly,
all that often,
unless it's like an elderly person or
maybe someone in the countryside or
whatever,
but most people will speak to you in
standard language and wherever you go,
if you speak the standard language,
they'll be able to speak it back to you,
unless it's one of those types of people
I mentioned they might not be able to
with that said,
it's a good idea to learn some of the
dialect before you come here and to
familiarize yourself with it just
passively.
You don't have to practice producing the
dialects or I'm getting fluent and using
the dialect.
You don't have to do that.
You just a book like this,
which just basically introduces some of
the words and shows them in context is
good just just for passive learning.
So you'll know it when you hear it.
And then over time as you live in that
location,
you will incorporate some of those
elements of the dialect into your
natural speech in the right situations.
Right?
Uh,
so just just do that.
Focus on the standard language and have
some fun learning a bit of the dialect
and over time it will become part of
your Japanese.
So that's my advice.
I hope that's helpful.
Alright,
talk to you later.
Bye.